appel général appelle général et si la
station française france2 ontario
portugal france 2 op maison des jeunes
de poitiers qui lance appel général sans
la présence sur ba m
mm-69 et 5 mg de france aux deux en
ontario portugal terrified 5 h r eh bien
mon cher ami
aujourd'hui elle fait dans ce cas
portugal nous avons la télévision
le
là
e
qui prend pas garde
la sépaq
tout ça
sans compter mais qui prend sa wii nous
visitons actuellement la maison des
jeunes et de la culture de poitiers où
notre caméra va de découverte en
découverte tandis que choristes et
danseuses travail
nous allons gagner la partie
administrative de la maison puis
découvrir avec son directeur
l'extraordinaire gamme de possibilités
mises à la disposition des saints oui
allô ici la cuisine le chef alors 120
couverts qu'on me dit merci madame
jean pierre de clages j'ai 18 ans 19 ans
et qu'est-ce qu'on fait comme métier
masson ya longtemps vous habitez à la mi
juin
vu depuis l'ouverture et miami c'est
complètement faux mais complètement
dessus chez moi ou ils nous chez moi et
la pension vous revient combien formant
il revient à 25 min amende est ce
qu'avant votre été plus difficile
c'était beaucoup plus difficile parce
qu'il vous payez plus que ça a dû payer
30 35 mi temps dans les petits cafés
fusil que ça il rentrait dans des
clapiers décaper et maintenant vous êtes
de chez vous je me sens très chic en
cuir et âme à dire que l'esprit de
muffins crédible
me sens pas j'étais chez moi
pour que plus de 10 personnes
je me semble c'est con si j'ai des
parents où j'ai retrouvé mes pensées
la maison des jeunes et de la culture de
poitiers que vous venez de visiter vient
d'ouvrir ses portes et déjà la
fréquentation de ses différentes
activités montrent que le succès qu'elle
remporte dépasse nos prévisions les plus
optimistes
construite sur un terrain appartenant à
la municipalité
sa construction a été menée par les
services d'architecturé de la ville sous
la direction de monsieur réjouissent la
précédente municipalité a lancé le
projet la municipalité actuelle on a
terminé les travaux d assure maintenant
son fonctionnement
mais d'autres organismes ou
collectivités ont participé à sa
construction
financièrement parlant ainsi le
ministère de la jeunesse et des sports
est également le ministère donne de la
population et la caisse nationale de
sécurité sociale
cela me bleux mans et tout les
aménagements intérieurs ont été fait en
collaboration et avec l'aide de la
caisse d'allocations familiales de la
vienne et également du conseil général
les différentes parties que vous avez
visité montre que cette maison se
compose de deux endroits essentiels
d'une part une partie culturelle composé
de différentes activités ateliers salles
de spectacles salle d'éducation physique
et d'autre part une partie sociale
cette partie sociale qui comprend d'une
part un foyer du jeune travailleur et
d'autre part un restaurant communautaire
a été volontairement adjointe à cette
partie culturelle en effet un début des
maisons des jeunes et de la culture et
de permettre non seulement aux jeunes et
aux adultes de pouvoir se connaître
s'apprécier et collaborer mais également
dans une ville universitaire comme le
nôtre à permettre aux jeunes
travailleurs comme aux jeunes étudiants
de pouvoir oeuvrer ensemble
en définitive le succès qu'elle connaît
montre bien que la maison des jeunes et
de la culture de poitiers correspondait
à un besoin et que si
on trouve que ces locaux modernes bien
agencé sont peut-être pour certains un
peu trop beau en général pour les jeunes
comme pour toute une population
rien n'est trop agréable pour mener à
bien l'oeuvre de promotion humaine que
nous nous sommes assignés